my name is Colin right Smith I'm a
digital media producer for the Berkman
Center for Internet and Society at
Harvard Law School it's a research
center they're looking at a number of
issues related to the internet and
society I'd like to just quickly thank
Peter Kaufman for inviting us to be here
it's been a very full and exciting
conference and we'd like to thank you
all for sticking around I should also
say before starting this is definitely a
primera Hancock presentation you'll
probably find out why once we show you
what we have today but we definitely
look forward to speaking with her after
our presentation if possible so I like
to first begin briefly with a short
story that explains how we got here and
then Dean will show you a brief
presentation of what we have as digital
media producer for the birkin center
I've been publishing audio and video
podcasts at the Berkman Center for the
past year and a half on a blog called
media berkman and during this time I've
been publishing with the system it's
really been cobbled together from a
variety of different platforms it's not
ideal and the process has been both
cumbersome and time-consuming I met Dean
who works for the participatory culture
Foundation which we'll hear more about
later when he worked on a video project
for the Berkman Center at this time we
realized that we needed a better
solution for the work that we were both
doing so about six months ago we sat
down and talked about the possibilities
for rebuilding the existing Berkman
Center media library we knew we wanted a
system that would allow students faculty
and staff to easily upload and share
media including audio video and text
like many of the other projects we've
seen during this conference this new
media library had to be easy to install
manage publish with and browse we also
needed something that wouldn't leave the
Berkman Center with the standalone silo
of content which we've also heard about
for many others during the
two days so we did a comprehensive
survey of existing solutions and found
nothing that specifically met the
Berkman centers needs and we still
haven't found anything particularly yet
but of course we've learned a lot from
this conference and many of the
presentations here we realized that we
were in a unique position to build a
piece of software that could fill both
the needs of the Berkman Center as well
as many of the many similar institutions
and we also discovered that there were
very few established best practices in
the space for metadata and centralized
searching among many other things so is
at that point when we knew the scope of
this project is much larger than where
it had began so at this point I'm in a
segue to Dean who's going to walk you
through conceptual mock-up of the open
media library hey I'm Dean Jensen I work
for I don't know which of these is
picking up I work for the participatory
culture foundation some of you guys
might be familiar with the democracy
player which is kind of a cool free and
open source tool for getting video sort
of the short the short version of it is
that it's kind of like itunes plus TiVo
for video it's free and open source
released under the GPL cross-platform
might be of interest to some of you so
check that out the project that the
Berkman Center at Harvard and the PCF
are working on together is the open
media library and this is sort of a
mock-up that we put together of the
front end of the the project and so I'll
just do a walk-through of some of the
features i'll go fairly quickly because
i imagine that people are a little more
interested in some of the technical
stuff that might be going on behind the
front side so just some of the bells and
whistles the ability to easily publish
media retaining the original format
also like transcoding to something like
flash having automatic playback in sort
of like the light box style that pops up
right over the screen doing some Ajax
tricks with that so that any video or
audio on the site can be instantly
previewed and played back the ability to
get like drop-down drawers with more
information on anything that you're
looking at so you you can get
description star ratings or you know
user ratings comments that sort of thing
where this this is not the final design
this is just sort of the very first
iteration so we're thinking of putting
in social features such as tagging and
kind of the the web two point O gamut
and let's see so if you close that
you're right back to where you started
and this next part is sort of where it
gets a little more to the library aspect
of this project so any time you run a
search or look at an author or I'm
pointing at my screen here I should be
pointing up here anytime you're doing a
search are looking at an individual
author or a project then you're going to
get a page that looks something like
this that has all of the media listed by
by type and this is just how word how we
would choose to display it but this
system would be obviously open source
and something that someone else could
customize with like ajax ajax drop down
so that you could reveal all of the
videos in the project etc etc really
easy access to the subscription
functions RSS like maybe it won't click
itunes or democracy and the ability to
choose various formats and this next
portion is another thing that is sort of
really key to what we're talking about
here we we didn't want to create
something that would just be that
standalone a silo so that you visit
Berkman's the Berkman centers website
and you search their video and maybe you
find something maybe not we wanted to
make some
thing that if peer institutions were
using the same system or they had maybe
ruled their own video publishing systems
that the back ends could sort of talk to
each other in order to do like a
centralized cross-site search so if I
look for information on internet
firewalls at the Berkman Center then I
see a little link that says we've got
these videos but you might check out
these extended results too and we've
been looking for a sort of a I don't
know best practice or a solution for
this and haven't really found anything
that seems suitable so we feel like this
could be sort of a project that blazed a
new trail in this area and so that's the
end of the the front side of the
presentation we just end with why we
think it's necessary and we've
definitely had a whole lot of interest
in this talking with people from public
broadcasting educators a lot of
different educators individuals a lot of
interest so we're just we feel like the
the dominoes are all lined up and we're
just looking for that final that that
little push to get started on this thing
and so I welcome any questions or that's
a good question there is right now the
Berkman Center and and PCF are ready to
start working on it and we're looking
for funders we put on we put out some
grant applications but haven't had any
word back yet I think they're still a
ways off from being finalized but where
we sort of need help finding funding so
I think probably
a lot of research and work with other
institutions at this point we had an
exciting meeting at the Berkman Center
in temporal that brought together folks
from MIT USC Yale Emerson College where
I'm a graduate student folks from public
broadcasting and public access
television to come together and start
you know chipping away at this at some
best practices for a project like this
but obviously again to reiterate you
know now we have learned that there are
other folks working in the space from
being here so it's very exciting for us
but what that day really helped us to do
is really identify some of the key both
technical and legal challenges which is
really so great about this conference
because it's exactly what we focused on
for our day-long meeting and we are
looking forward to bringing back all
what we've learned from this conference
to our group there with absolutely the
intention of plugging into existing
groups that are obviously working in
this effort so that we can join with
other people in this area so we're very
excited about that